ああああああん
see
ああいや by ちょっと風邪引いたかも知れませ鼻水がアドリブが止まりません
肇社長です皆さんは身近なものどこまで目を通せてますか
まあ世の中そのシェアが広いとか狭いということがあるんですけどもやっぱりね
c が広い人間になりたい味を
r
やっぱりもう目先のものばっかりではなくてねと目先の目標に向かいつつも白い視野で
いろんなものを見て自分だけじゃなく周りの人のことも考えて動きたいですよね
我々にイエローからちょっとねすごい細かいマイナーチェンでにどこまでその雅紀が
築けるかどうかっていうんですかねのでシェアの広させば卒と比べてみようと思います
今度はいえするのはこちら
今回はこちら自転車のサドルです
えっ
なんかろいねえレーサーがサドルというのがあるんですけども普通に入らず電車に
取り付けるこの伊勢座るところですもうこれから普通にこれコーチ電車乗る市してある
と思うんですけども
もうズレ茶屋さんにこれ3つ持っていく僕の絵をそうそうしてみてください
ただのアホですよと言うで今回はですね雑っ記が最近自転車働くしたというわけで混ぜ
た分
自転車のことを見投げてないんですよね便の自転車のその造形美色
式采配やなサイズツールの大きさた家の膨らみ過去の目の数ブレーキの効きやす例えば
そんなに細かく把握してないと思うんで今回ちょっと事前者ので軽くマイナーチェンジ
してそれに幕引き柄ドットコムで試してみたいと思いますなぜキーワードいいとこだと
思う本当にと武器ずっと気づかねーか b
ようならいいんだと思います静か気づけないか分からない物ってそうそうないですから
ながら子が読めばいいともに目をつけたと思います
今回は自分の自転車のサドルをすり替えられると気づく気付かないかなときりでござい
ます気づけたら視野の広い人間ちょっと本文に気づく気付かないか微妙なラインなので
ぜひとも行ってみたかった
で梅香ない土をつけてねああ
すみません聞こえませんでしたラッシュ
恋愛店でとカッター
私行くん
このアーセンこれここで入っ
ちょっと寄ったら他の紀年寝具店別体にどうすんだよ
なんかいう行事ね違うしできてないからたーーー
変数いってられたで終わらせるもうそう
ああああああああ
noa
えっ
u 10ですねじゃあ郷中させてくれるん
ani ん
ああああああ
イーコレ
気をつけているはいあーん
いきます
入ってるんですたべちゃんなんかやっちゃん行ってらっしゃい
されたばいばーいうっ
始め
これなんやハーブスパ
これなんやこれああそうです
ドイツ胸やこれああいや殺さ誰
ああああハ
気付かだと思っ
そういうんじゃないぞなめとんのかはございません
ああ
ありがとうございません
中に入ってネクローっ
me
うううう
パパッ日